in five four three two one we always do
a countdown before we start the genius
brain we all know this is a Thursday so
it's me and the bestest host co-host on
earth Joe Jitsu [ __ ] cow a
[ __ ] yeah what's up homie stick him up
and I am your other host David so how
has everybody's week been I hope that
the the great Nordic gods have blessed
your beards and is growing down all the
way to the top of your penis you stupid
lovely people what is it beard No Shave
November and no nut November's is that
what that is no-shave November but by
the time this comes out it's probably
like December I don't even know there's
two things going on
I think it's no-shave November huh and
they have to know nuttin what's the burn
what's the point of no not November
what's the point of that [ __ ] no fat
there's you know have you heard of the
no fat movement why apparently there's
science out there that says like when
you jack off all kinds of [ __ ] happens
negatively you get depressed and all
this stuff and lies when I jack off I
feel like a brand new man
what are they talking about when I jack
off I feel great yeah I know but I guess
it just deal I don't know make some have
low self esteem I don't know man I don't
I can't quote it right but I just did go
the I just read I just read all this
[ __ ] I watched a bunch of videos it's a
whole thing cuz guys are jacking off way
too much to the point where they're not
even talking to girls because they're
like well [ __ ] I got my porn and even if
they start having sex and [ __ ] they're
like wolves never as good as jacking off
and born so Owen in like if they if they
already released like they're not
motivated to like work are not motivated
to hit on girls or like there's just a
lot of other issues I guess only issues
and things but I don't know you know for
me I I just get too busy now that I
don't even have time to [ __ ] beat it
like no we're [ __ ] busy like we'll
wake up and as soon as we wake up we got
to start working like a [ __ ] we
get home you're just so tired did you
just close your eyes and you knock the
[ __ ] out and you do it again you know
it's funny uh when I was younger porn
you know even younger and everybody says
it should if you want to fall asleep you
should jackoff and then fall asleep if I
jack off before I fall asleep I can't go
to sleep
really
you sleep that [ __ ] wakes me up it wakes
me a ham so I'm about if you have sex
though that's different because that's
work like I got it I got a work you
should I got a sweat but jacking off I
think you know when I jack off it's
pretty quick that's good the relief I
get from sex though is different from
jacking off like if I jack off and I
[ __ ] bust a nut and I'm like okay
whatever my last a few [ __ ] hours or
like maybe like one day but then if I
get to [ __ ] then it's like four days I'm
like the happiest most saddest maxed
chill person it's true what they say
it's like oh that phone needs to get
laid or like that girl needs to get dick
or whatever like to me I think that's so
[ __ ] true you just need a [ __ ]
[ __ ] and it has to be good sex and
you should [ __ ] just [ __ ] like a maniac
and you're just like what violence what
dude that's why people always say why do
guys want to [ __ ] [ __ ] a [ __ ] so
much because that's where we came from
we're just going back home don't worry
about it dude that's what Rome says we
just uh we're trying to go back home oh
my nice and comforting we're going back
to the source dude why are you even
asking questions like that you know I
opened up a Twitter and then on the
Twitter I'm you know I'm just [ __ ]
I'm a troll dude it's like I will I
wrote down um if you don't have a brain
then you must give week head well like
your head game must be week yeah cuz
like I'm basically like if you don't if
you don't have no brain then your head
game must be week so it's like I'm
trying to filter the dumb girls so then
it's like oh that's clever but they're
my friends like hey even though it's a
play on like giving head they might not
get that and they might think you're
just a perv that's like and I'm like
well yeah and he was but do you want
more hits a more chances or do you want
everyone thinking that you're just a
perv and I'm like oh my god I'm so
[ __ ] stupid I was like no wonder I
wasn't getting any hits so I did change
it cause I'm like boring ass [ __ ] well
hey I like to travel I like to eat you
know or like some normal ass [ __ ] and I
started getting [ __ ] likes after that
dude dude that's funny because those
dating apps they base your person
because they're trying to base your
personality off of these small instances
yeah so they see these little little
descriptors of you and some of the stuff
that I've seen for
are literally the dumbest things I've
ever seen in my life it's like oh yeah
because if surfing ain't in your life
then I'm not gonna try to make you my
wife like [ __ ] like this like my life or
it's just like I like to have fun but
I'm serious at the same time and I'm a
hopeless romantic shut the [ __ ] up dude
say how you actually are that she didn't
go and work on nobody bro if anything
else have a nice looking picture and
just state what you do for a living how
much you make yeah and then the [ __ ]
that you like and leave it at that dude
I like long walks on the beach who
[ __ ] doesn't yeah [ __ ] I like to
travel well [ __ ] I bet a girl I don't
know any girl that's looking at that and
going oh you like to travel
[ __ ] why traveling and I think tinder is
so not even just tinder just a lot of
these dating apps are super fun because
I know a couple guys I was telling you
earlier how they travel and they
literally write when they land they open
up their dating apps and they meet up
people Wow and sometimes it's to hook up
other times it's just to have a travel
buddy that you meet there and then you
guys experience whatever that kind of
fun yeah it's it's I'm gonna try that I
don't know you're single I'll try it but
yeah I think I don't like for me I think
I like talking to people and filtering
them I guess you could do that on tinder
right yes see if you match I like
someone with this has sense of humor I
like too
I'm not too serious just to play around
and then so like if I can connect and
I'll probably do that but at the same
time that's a huge commitment just
travel with the [ __ ] stranger like ha
man
what if you're annoyed and you're just
like how do you get rid of them
I guess it's kind of like a dating
situation too or just like I'm good if
they want to meet up tomorrow you're
like I'm good man like I'll see ya I'll
see you some other time yeah cuz I don't
know I mean I just want to meet people
that I already like if that makes any
sense I mean you're gonna have to filter
that [ __ ] out cuz you never know that's
true you don't know what's gonna happen
yeah cuz I I connected with a few people
locally and whatever on tinder but it's
just a different thing it's just I'm not
I'm so out of the loop man are you
somebody that when you when you meet
somebody do you in can you instantly
tell whether you're gonna buy with them
or not or do you have to hang out with
them a little bit first and see what
happens I could
by the way we interact online already
mmm like if we're typing back and forth
and if I actually feel myself enjoying
the conversation then I'm probably gonna
pursue it in person because there are
cute [ __ ] girls right that I'm like
damn you're [ __ ] hot right and then
like I make a few exchanges and I'm like
I'm not gonna enjoy this person's
company yeah cuz I can already tell you
could tell a person's mind by the way
they communicate and I don't think you
know it some guys they'll just be like
immediately let's meet up but for me
I'll take weeks of just chatting with
them to see if they're worth it
mmm then I take a long time because for
me it's easy to just type and not spend
a whole day cuz you know how [ __ ]
busy we are right yeah and like even
though you're meeting with someone for
dinner or lunch that's a long commitment
for me that's really like if you're
driving there you're eating you're
hanging out that's a three for our
commitment I'm just too busy for that
[ __ ] so for me I'll just type type type
oh do I get along do I connect are we
attracted to each other I can kind of
gauge it and then for me it's like let
me just continue this conversation and
see where it goes I think I owe ya I
think I just had to hang out and see
with that I don't know if I'm too
judgmental when I meet people but I
usually just go by my gut feeling and I
leave it at that
there are certain people that I've met
on the first jump and then I've just
kind of dismissed how they were and I
was they did be dismissive of them but I
always just go by the gut feeling if I
have a bad gut feeling about it I don't
say like oh maybe I'm wrong I always
just follow it and it tended to work out
a lot of the times I say like I'm
throwing out a random percentage because
I'm not actually calculating this
obviously but I think like 90% of the
time when I have a gut feeling about
something that I don't like them usually
those behaviors either come out and I
don't think it's a self-fulfilling
prophecy they just have this they it
always comes out later on worth within a
group of friends they go yeah they're
kind of a shady person like and it all
starts to come out I'm like what you
never was like but she's so fine oh my
god she's so fun her guts nobody's like
I think when they open them you know
what I'm when I find really annoying
it's like I actually like best
girls voice so if I don't like your
voice I can't I can't date you like if
your voice annoys me oh yeah you have a
really sometimes it's too pitchy or too
weird like - high-pitched uh-huh I can't
[ __ ] stand that [ __ ] I I move on even
if they're [ __ ] pretty I just can't
stand their voice I can't do it that's
true it's like a stinky breath you know
no matter how [ __ ] Hoshi is it's like oh
man
I can't breathe that's why [ __ ] that's
why I like my even like they're so funny
when my dad back in the day he would try
to set me up with a lot of these Korean
girls right yeah he goes obviously you
never have a girlfriend I'm gonna set
you up with a nice accordion girl
in the worst state tastes right dog if I
could show you what the [ __ ] these girls
look like it's like I'm talking about
the white Skechers the acid-wash jeans
the [ __ ] college white collar shirt
with the button on top and then where's
the baseball cap type of [ __ ] dude she
looks like she's about to go golf huh
dude has never used any makeup
whatsoever has no sense of style fashion
whatever just does an also by the way
they never spoke English Oh even better
right like what [ __ ] and I'm looking at
my dad I'm like yo man this is this is
not the business deal I don't even know
if I told you this story dude this
shit's a [ __ ] house I might put into a
script later but why not just tell him
here you guys might see in a movie but
so my dad doesn't know about my personal
dating life right because I don't share
any of that [ __ ] with him I don't want
to just because he's super noisy and
kind of annoying and at that time I
didn't really get along with him so
anything that I would tell him he would
just spin it out of control and he'll
give you advice and try to control you
and all that exactly so one time this is
during the time I was a youth minister
at this church that he started up so I
get there and after church my dad's like
hey I want to introduce you to somebody
and I'm like who who do you want to
introduce me to and he goes I wanna
introduce you to girl night nah I'm good
he goes no no it's nothing like that
like I just want you to hang out I just
see her she's new in town
hey and this girl looked like she bench
pressed like at least she look like a
rugby player dude she was bought off she
was just like thick you know II got
again swimmers she was she looked she
looked like the golfer she had the Hat
she
was wearing a hoodie and a no shirt at
all huh I was like I guess she's she
might be a sweet girl whatever I'm not
gonna try to go on a date with her but
this will try to set me up at a blind
date at church with her parents right
there so I couldn't say no so I I said
okay cool like I'll take her out around
town or whatever says she's new to the
area
yeah so check this [ __ ] out I can't I
cannot make this [ __ ] up so I probably
feeling like that too probably she's
like [ __ ] my parents so you will see
this right so one day so when I would do
my ministry at the church the after that
I would go to another Church to get my
own sermon you know and a different
church and those one in Davis so this
girl she wanted to go to Davis and she
goes hey can you know can I come along
with you to go to church after and I was
like all right cool so I got kind of
blindsided on this blind date so we go
there the church is closed and you know
it's really awkward conversations and
this is on the drive back so uh in the
drive back all of a sudden I were
driving and I turn turn on some music
she goes to my music not but she dials
all the music that she turns it off why
I don't know she's honest I guess but
she just turned the music I was like
okay that was a little weird and I don't
like to turn it up a little bit she
shuts it right off again and I'm like
what okay this is a little weird and as
we're driving I don't remember what
she's saying forbidden because it's
happened quite a few years ago but it
would be like some [ __ ] where she just
in there just like yeah I don't I don't
want to do no no don't don't do this to
me what are you doing right now I stop
she's talking to herself and I'm like
the [ __ ] do this mister and then so I
looked over I was like oh she's fine as
a Bluetooth in her ear right so I kind
of ignored it and she no stop stop
don't don't don't do this and I'm like I
look over there's nothing in her ear
she's [ __ ] talking to herself oh [ __ ]
talking to herself and I'm like yo are
you okay like who are you talking to
right she goes oh I kind of don't want
to talk about this right now and I'm
like what don't you want to talk about
like are you cool are you ok because I
wanted to see if I need to pull over so
[ __ ] and I'm in the middle of the
freeway this is a long-ass freeway from
Davis to Sacramento yeah you took her on
a long as road trip as it was like 35
minutes 40 minutes so that's how far I
used to go to go to church and then she
would just be like then she wouldn't
miss you the dishes she goes yeah I
should goes I'm talking to my
ex-boyfriend right now and I'm like oh
like like well you had a Bluetooth or
some
and she goes no he speaks speaks to me
telepathically bro I'm not making this
[ __ ] [ __ ] up if she was he's speaking
to me telepathically and I'm and bro I'm
laughing right I thought she was joking
and like you have a connection like the
Avatar tog
so I started cracking up I thought she
was busting the joke and look at her
deadpan not a joke and I'm like yo
what's about to scare you so you don't
[ __ ] come on to her so I thought she
was like kind of [ __ ] around or
whatever yeah and then she goes yeah
like so if he goes if you look at my
boyfriend's eyes he she goes one of his
eyes is it's like steel cold grey and
his split half in blue and that shows
that he knows he knows telepathy he goes
when I was when I was we used to live
together and I'm just telling him right
now to leave me alone
because the last time I was with him he
was talking to me he made me burn down a
house bro
I started sweating I thought she was
going I thought she was gonna take the
wheel and then [ __ ] throw us off on
the freeway so I was sweating [ __ ]
bullets holding the wheel super tight
and I turned the music and I should turn
it down I guess you goes I can't hear
him she's like yelling at me at this
point
whoa yo what the [ __ ] is going on right
now that at that point I was so [ __ ]
scared cuz she kept on telling me the
stories I don't remember them all right
now I might be able to replicate if I
really think about it but she was
telling me the story about how she like
telepathically controlled her yeah and
had her burned down the house that they
were staying at yeah and then she had a
she burned another house that she loves
burning it else's she goes yeah he's
talking to me she's like and as words
she's telling the story she goes shut up
shut up shut up shut up oh and so I'm
freaking out I finally get to our house
at the driveway
I drop her off like hey it's nice
meeting you like I'll hit you up some
other time she goes well let me get your
number I don't know oh [ __ ] and at this
point I was thinking to myself I should
give her a fake number I was like you
should I give her a fake number of my
real number yeah and so I was like I
should probably give her my real number
just in case so I gave her my real
number right and as and she leaves and
as I'm backing out she calls my phone's
looking into my car she goes oh I just
wanted to see if this was a fake number
ho and I Drive back I go to
dad yeah and I'm like yo what the [ __ ]
was that I was like how the [ __ ] I was
like did you know she's like a
schizophrenic she's talking to human
beings in her head and all my dad goes
oh that's so funny and he starts he
starts dying laughing he pranked you
know he didn't know but he just thought
it was so funny I was like dawg
she could've [ __ ] killed me dude Wow
so she was so what I found out later on
was that she was trying to go I guess
she's been trying to get into the Navy
or whatever but she couldn't pass like a
psych eval obviously she's [ __ ] crazy
turns out she wasn't schizophrenic dude
she was like dealing with like
schizophrenia and her you know like
Asian parents they don't believe in
mental illness they're like oh she's
just a little weird she's a [ __ ]
schizophrenic it may be in [ __ ] no oh
[ __ ] so they they saw this obviously
this behavior might be happening in the
house yeah so they were just trying to
keep it under wraps I guess and I guess
for them kind of what I'm concluding
they're probably like thank God David
take her take her ass and marry her oh I
got her out of the [ __ ] house I got
[ __ ] pissed so my dad talked to their
parents yeah and this is why I'm
assuming I assumed that she just gets a
frantic because she's talking to people
or whatever whatnot and then my dad was
explained to me after as he's laughing
and this is this is after he laughed the
first time this is the second time
because I talked to them and I guess
she's you know she has like some issues
here and there I was like that's not
some issues they refused to recognize
that she has a mental illness yeah she
needs help she needs [ __ ] help and
they set me up on a blind date with a
schizophrenic dude yeah one of the worst
blind dates I ever have that she laughed
and [ __ ] died stop shut up shut up
shut up
that's [ __ ] scary and he's talking to
me right now
my ex-boyfriend no I don't want to order
pizza yeah yes she was like yes half
half gray eyes and half blue or green if
you even have an ex-boyfriend that's
what I'm saying I don't even think she
did but she's like but she was saying
that he was he was talking to her
telepathically and the last time they
were they were together he would control
her mind and had her burned down her
name her neighbor's house or some [ __ ]
that is [ __ ] crazy see that's the
part of dating that I don't like is like
you don't know these people
and they could be the sweetest cuz you
know everyone has [ __ ] baggage like
all of our friends all of our family
members everyone has something wrong
with them or some issue that they're
dealing with right that eventually is
gonna spill on to you and whatever your
issues are is gonna spill on to them I
it's crazy because I I went on when I
was so after my first girlfriend and I
broke up I kind of had this whole thing
I did a whole little miniseries and
people want me to continue it which I
might the where uh I I I kind of focused
only on one girl in high school cuz I
was such a [ __ ] loser and after that
I was like I'm gonna date anybody and
everybody just because I don't even know
what I like I wanna I want to do the
exact opposite of this [ __ ] girl and
just date whoever but because I have so
many random dating stories because I
think I [ __ ] you not when I came back
from Riverside and I started going to
Community College any opportunity that
could date somebody I started dating
people specifically because I wanted
stand-up stories because I noticed that
my stand-up was so [ __ ] weak and I
kept on doing Asian jokes and which
which was they were hitting at the time
but it was I was kind of biting off of
like just all these Asian stereotypes
which I molded it well but it was like I
wanted to speak more than that so I
started dating cuz I thought you know I
think relationship stuff and dating
stuff is very relatable
so I started dating every [ __ ] girl
so I don't like a thousand [ __ ]
stories I haven't written him in a
notebook somewhere big of my old
stand-up up all these weird dating
situations but that was one of them was
when my dad set me on a [ __ ] blind
date with the schizophrenic that's
pretty crazy that was one of the war
situations I've ever [ __ ] been in and
it's so hard to tell cuz like it almost
sounds [ __ ] unbelievable but yeah
just ask my [ __ ] dad and he'll
probably crack up as you mentioned the
story to him it was [ __ ] cry I still
remember what she looks like till this
day white [ __ ] hoodie wrapped up in
her head white golf cap the [ __ ] the
faded blue jeans the white Skechers and
then she had her hoodie tied in a knot
like up here and it was super tight
around her head [ __ ] man that's some
serial killer sure issue the the what
she wore at church was the same thing
that she wore the day that we went out
and did she change clothes she didn't
change clothes she just wore the same
outfit so when you guys were on the way
there
she was fine and you guys were doing the
whole praise circle
or whatever everything was fine also we
couldn't go into the church because I
guess there was like a holiday then and
and then church was closed oh time and
it got shifted to another time so he
missed sermons so he went all the way
back so I just drove the Davis and I
drove all oh yeah and she's dog and the
only reason I know about the whole Navy
stuff that she was trying to get into
the Navy because the conversation there
was perfectly fine she was talking about
her wanting to get into Navy and also
the shed or II she didn't have a granola
bar or something and she started
freaking out I don't know what the [ __ ]
that was but that [ __ ] was crazy because
when she was talking to talking to
herself I thought she was talking on a
Bluetooth yeah that [ __ ] does [ __ ] with
people that wouldn't you know the
Bluetooth when it started coming out I
was like so many people talking to
themselves yeah [ __ ] or like still say
[ __ ] and I'm all like yes and I'm like
oh man [ __ ] you I've had so many [ __ ]
weird datings at you I gotta look into
that [ __ ] old stand a book that I
have I used to write that [ __ ] on a
notebook all the time and this is before
I would use like the Apple notes and
[ __ ] yeah I used to write that [ __ ] any
any chance that I had I thought
something funny I would write it down
and all these dates and these funny
moments that I had I would I to make
sure that it either go into stand-up or
some type of script you ever had blank
dates before back in a day online before
there was pictures before all that [ __ ]
no I only the only type of blind dates
that I had was when I think I got hooked
up with from through a friend or some
[ __ ] man I remember back in the [ __ ]
day right like junior high days like
before Facebook all that [ __ ]
it was so [ __ ] old school that you
meet people online and you had to wait
for them to send you pictures in snail
mail dude you [ __ ] make it funny
because not everyone had scanners oh
yeah yeah yeah scanners are expensive
dude you have to [ __ ] get your
picture and you have to scan that
picture and then you had to [ __ ]
upload it and like you know like no one
was taking selfies and [ __ ] and so you
get like one photo of somebody in your
email and then like most people didn't
have pictures so people lied like a
[ __ ] who they really were
I remember like this girl I [ __ ]
connected with I thought she was cool
and I was and then we have phone sex and
I was like what 14 or some [ __ ] and I
was like Dan's going
gonna marry his girl right now phone sex
dude that she sends me a picture
in the [ __ ] mail and I felt I didn't
know what to do because she was cute but
she was like too wholesome you know like
yeah you know we're young at that age
you want [ __ ] ABG lytes mom right you
want the [ __ ] McDonald eyebrows and a
blonde hair import model look you didn't
know what she looked like I didn't know
like you just connected and chatted back
then really yeah and then like when I
got her picture in the mails like man
you look like you're [ __ ] 12 dude but
I'm 14 but 12 and 14 is a stretch at
that time and I'm like I don't know what
to do and I just go stood her ass
that's [ __ ] she was so her too and I
felt bad but I don't know what the [ __ ]
did do man and she's probably [ __ ]
beautiful now but at that time I didn't
like innocent clean looking girls yeah
cuz in my head they didn't look like
women yeah I don't like I was being a
molester like yeah they look young and
and cute like in that way like I wanted
[ __ ] bad girls with like a tattoo on
their [ __ ] butt cheek or something
yeah yeah yeah cuz they I don't know
maybe that represented women to me but
like I've done like there's been times
were like alright like you talked to
girls online right and they send a
picture and they'll send you like one
and you're like oh [ __ ] she's hot right
but it's like not really that's a
glamour photo at the mall where they're
like turned her back and you see a
profile picture or whatever hella [ __ ]
glossy or whatever filters they put on
and in me my buddies were like I didn't
drive at the time so I was like can
let's go [ __ ] pick her up and then
like you guys could drop us off at the
at the movie theater so he pull up in
his girl man she was real big dude like
I'm gonna get cancelled for this [ __ ]
but I was 14 okay [ __ ] yeah we
pull up because I have my 16 year old
friend driving the car and then he had
his other buddy 15 he was in the front I
was in the back we pull up she and I see
her get out of the [ __ ] she gets out
of the door she waves to us we're part
and I said go go [ __ ]
I said go go go
you're [ __ ] and she was like waving
and we [ __ ] went dude dog that [ __ ]
up I bet you she's [ __ ] fit as [ __ ]
right now I yeah I hope so dude I I
didn't know what to do that was like the
catalyst for her to start it this sounds
like a [ __ ] movie dude where the girl
was bigger whole life and then she gets
the biggest rejection after the guy she
was and you know what you know what this
is I was really skinny too can you
imagine
oh you were that I was 115 pounds laughs
so I wasn't a [ __ ] catch either but
that I just looked at that image like
god damn like like how do you imagine a
really big girl with a really skinny guy
so let's say her weight is ha let's say
how much does she weigh this she how
tall was she I don't remember I just
remember she was like oh she was a
Humpty Dumpty's level like she was bald
she was like round round so I was like
shoot I didn't that was not the picture
that I saw yeah at all dude and um and
also I was very embarrassed yeah because
like I think if it was just us two I
would have just [ __ ] hung out with
her yeah because because your friends
were probably judging you as [ __ ] - yeah
and then I when we pulled up I was like
go go go and they were laughs and like
they're laughing at that girl it's
probably [ __ ] yeah it are like go go go
go we're going out of here and then we
[ __ ] live and then they were just the
whole time just laughing man could you
imagine that girl just standing there
and that somebody saw her and they just
ran away yeah poor girl because she like
she was 15 or 16 at the time - so she
was older than me but I was like man
that was so weird
I feel really bad to this day you know
but I think I don't know when you're at
that age you don't know how to act you
don't know how to think you don't know
about what the other person is dealing
with you just react right you just like
Oh
Rod's you know it's funny too like I
remember when uh when I started going
into these underaged clubs and [ __ ] and
we would dance and [ __ ] and then you
know you
started riding up on whatever girl in
mind you I look I look disgusting
and you know we would be grinding up and
after a while girls not really form the
issue a walk away and I'm like do you
think that offends me I was like I got
my [ __ ] in you touch me lady that's got
my feels yeah I got my fields that spank
bank material you actually did your job
thank you very much I appreciate you
don't feel bad I don't feel bad so we're
good there's a good trader oh my god
it's crazy cause like I think I don't
know when I was maybe it was because I
was trying to do comedy so much I don't
think I really gave a [ __ ] about what I
look like
because I was trying to be funny you
know this podcast is brought to you by
vistaprint Bay Bay listen if you're a
business man or woman out there and you
don't have business cards what are you
doing you want your business cards to
look dope because when you're doing
these like great social functions and
you meet somebody that you think wants
your services well guess what you better
have a business card ready to go because
not everybody wants to stand there and
wait for you to jot down a phone number
instead pass them a card so they know
that you mean business they know that
they have your contact at all times
that's what I have man I'm a business
entrepreneur on top of that I'm a
podcaster on top of that I'm goning so I
have a stack of business cards ready to
go to hand out and make sure that you
got yours too my friends because
vistaprint has your back your next big
opportunity my friends is coming right
now and we're to help here to help you
own the now with free shipping on any
business cards in any quantity you can
choose whatever style finish shape or
paper you like and get free shipping and
because you can pick the colors fonts
designs and images it means you can
create something as unique and
compelling as your business just plug
your information and logo into hundreds
of fresh designs tailored to your type
of company or upload your own original
layout pick the paper stock style and
quantity that's right for you you can
even upgrade to a unique touch like
rounded corners order and receive your
cards with free economy shipping so guys
Vistaprint wants you to be able to own
the now in any situation which is why
our listeners will get free shipping on
all business cards any style any
quantity just
vistaprint.com and interpro moco brain
for free shipping on all business cards
any style any quantity limited time
offer own the now at vistaprint.com
promo code brain yeah I think that's
different like when you have a different
agenda if you were like I want I want a
relationship I want love I want to have
sex right then that is a huge strike to
your ego but if you're like I want
comedy material you almost feel
invincible yeah because you're like you
know [ __ ] the more embarrassing the
better the more ridiculous the better
don't remember I just do all these shows
and flip flops and socks and a t-shirt
and basketball shorts and it wasn't
because I couldn't get some pants and
whatever and dressed nice it's just it
just was funnier that way yeah it is
pretty funny you know I would show red
carpet events in flip-flops and I would
do it just despite my manager just
because he would get so mad I wanted to
do the same thing I was like [ __ ] this
like [ __ ] the norm
[ __ ] [ __ ] everybody having a look like
this yeah I'm a walking with my tank top
yeah I used to enjoy doing that [ __ ] but
after a while too
I just it's not that I don't want to do
it now it's just all right it's kind of
immature though yeah it's just being
different just to be different yeah it's
kind of like look at me I'm so cool
because like everyone's fancy and I'm
not if you guys look back into my old
videos you'll see a majority the shirts
that I wore were all free t-shirts I
think almost all of them were they're
all free t-shirts and it'll is a lot for
me it was an inside joke so I wouldn't
wear like all these like car wash
t-shirts all this other other dumb [ __ ]
and it was just an inside joke that I
was doing then nobody really knew about
because I I think I wanted to
it wasn't even my thing I wanted to show
people that like you could like comedy
you don't have to be good-looking you
don't have to do anything I think it's
worse if you're good-looking in comedy
yeah I just want to show people like yo
you could just be funny be funny yeah do
that first like don't don't worry about
all the other aesthetic [ __ ] like if
you're funny and you're content dope
it's gonna speak for itself so I don't
know if I was trying to be like like an
anti culturist type of dude but I just
wanted to show people that you don't
have to look a certain way to be
successful that's why even when I did
music I just did music because I looked
I didn't look the type that could sing
that well yeah so I enjoyed doing [ __ ]
like that cuz it was you know breaking
out from the norm cuz you care more
about the skill than you do about
anything else oh yeah for sure because
the other thing is just kind of like
bells and whistles yeah and and you know
not to say that if you guys ever go into
a certain art yeah the way that you look
will will affect how people view you
that's just how it is because it's an
entertainment thing it's not so much you
as a person but you as an entertainer
yeah right you'll see that too if you
guys saw the show on Netflix it's called
the hustle and the rhythm and flow and
it's like American Idol for hip-hop oh
cool so when when they're auditioning
these people to go into the next round
it's like I'll talk about cardi B chance
to rapper they got Snoop Dogg everybody
in there they're not just looking for
you to be a dope rapper they want to see
your stage presence they want to see how
you dress if you can dance they were an
entertainer exactly they want to see
everything cuz you can't just go up
there have some like dope bars and rap
and then I'm like a homeless man yeah
and then all of a sudden when you
perform you're so stiff it's not
entertaining so they look for a whole
package when it comes to entertainment
and that that conversation was kind of
hard I had a friend she was like an OG
youtuber and I think for her she
couldn't she doesn't really I don't know
if she still sings anymore but she
couldn't really like understand and I
don't know if I explained it to her well
in a very nice way but she was like yeah
like I I make great music I was like you
make I was like you know I don't know if
you would say you make great music it's
like your music is decent you haven't
found your sound yet but on top of that
too you know when you make these videos
number one you don't care about the
production quality you don't care about
how you look in it which I'm not saying
[ __ ] it's all based on looks but people
are coming to you too they want to be
you and they want to sing like you yeah
and you're only giving them half the
package so yeah you can be successful
just on your voice alone but it doesn't
mean that there aren't other things you
could do to help you along the way
that's true right why do you think some
of these [ __ ] terrible YouTube
singers they're not even good but they
look [ __ ] good yeah and people just
want to be them you know that's true
yeah for me I'm like I actually don't
mind getting dressed up doing my hair
like I like looking a certain way I'm
not obsessed about it
but what what gets to me is my laziness
cuz I don't like to think yeah I don't
like to think of my outfit
if someone had something for me and to
like Joe put this on you look good
I'm like oh [ __ ] does cool let's go yeah
but when I have to I think I just have
too many other things on my mind so less
than you care about yeah cuz when I was
in Vietnam and vacationing Danny is
actually a very fashionable [ __ ]
so like I'll put some [ __ ] on you'd be
like hey Joe try these shoes try this
thing right here try this vest you'll
just throw [ __ ] at me and I'm like
mixing and matching and I'm like you
know this is kind of fun man it's like
it's just changing [ __ ] up and then
you'll be like alright we're gonna go
this place and get some photos here he's
very visually like artistic right and
I'm like oh yeah this can be a fun thing
but it takes time and a lot of brain
energy dude yeah it does and I don't
want to think that way I'm more like
[ __ ] Mark Zuckerberg you know just
wear the same [ __ ] shirt every single
day that's what I like that's why it's
funny too cuz I I [ __ ] love fashion I
love clothes and I keep up with a lot of
that [ __ ] it's just you know people are
like oh like secret society you know we
love the clothing blah blah but I don't
never see you wear clothes because I'm
too busy doing the other end of it yeah
you know it's if I have to put my time
and energy into doing that part it's
it's it's very difficult I mean even
today we had it we had a sit photo shoot
so I'm not wearing basketball shorts and
a shirt I got my hair done I got my hair
cut like yeah me too
yeah but other than that color shirt
yeah other than that like it's not
something that I'm really gonna do no
because it took time today it took time
like for me to shower get ready do my
hair get my hair cut do all of the [ __ ]
when in reality what we'll do is we'll
work out and if we get a chance to rinse
we're [ __ ] lucky yeah we'll work out
and we'll in workout clothes that we
worked out it we're just doing meetings
we're doing this we're doing that and
then we go home and we shower to go okay
time to sleep yep and I do the most
mindless [ __ ] when I get home yeah I get
home I look at my phone
and I just start playing plant vs.
zombies and the thing with fashion too
is the so like if I wear this a couple
times on camera or like once on camera
it's done yeah or if you wear it to an
event it's done right you got to keep
buying [ __ ] mm-hmm you got a key like
you got to sit there you got to go to
the mall or you got a you got to kind of
build your arsenal I [ __ ] hate that
[ __ ] dude
yeah and then you have a bunch of
clutter in your house and you're like
what am I gonna do with all this [ __ ]
cuz I'm a pack rat and I don't throw
[ __ ] away so I just have all these
clothes and I'm like oh they're outdated
but what am I gonna do I were like the
same two pairs of shoes I don't need all
this [ __ ] man
I am I got [ __ ] because I I bought
this psyche I did this [ __ ] but a lot of
people were doing when they were losing
weight which is getting a whole bunch of
what what I would wear if I was been
closed right
too bad that [ __ ] took [ __ ] eight
years and by the time I we go where I
could why I lost so much weight I move
past those oh I was already thinner than
that and then when I looked at the
clothes I was like this [ __ ] is so dated
damn who the [ __ ] is gonna wear this
stuff dude cuz it was like stuff that
was fashionable like maybe let me not
ten years ago but it's like oh jeans
southpaw
you got some FUBU and you're like one
day man one day I'm gonna wear these
FUBU [ __ ] finally wear it there was a
time where they had like the long tees
and it was extended with the bandana
Princeton [ __ ] and that [ __ ] was hot in
hip-hop but that was like seven years
ago like a street wear and I looked at
the [ __ ] as I did not wear this [ __ ]
dude you know that's what happened to
the secret society shirts you gave me a
long tease yeah cuz I got fat as [ __ ]
right I'm all like man I'm not gonna
look right into [ __ ] dude
I look like a pregnant mom like what the
long T I was like I never wore it cuz I
was like I'm not good dude I'm gonna
[ __ ] it and lose sales for your company
if I wear that [ __ ] I wasn't wearing
barbell chicks I'm like I'm not living
that fit life yeah that's why I was like
all right I gotta get fit and then you
guys move past that and you have more
designs now so I'm like what the [ __ ]
dude I think the word yeah we got some
other stuff coming up man it's it's
interesting they're like how fashion
moves though a lot of the stuff that was
popping back when we were younger it's
it's back all that retro 80s 90s [ __ ]
like I just went to Nike recently and I
got a bunch of their shorts and track
ship but it's all like camera looking
[ __ ] yeah dude it's like the neon green
and the orange [ __ ] like the shorts I
was wearing do they have that the neon
green stripe and the orange stripes it's
gonna come back hell yeah dude that's
why when factually just recycled herself
yeah it constantly recycled itself all
the time there was a certain point where
shoulder pads were coming in for women
yeah the [ __ ] puffy and the [ __ ] I
you see my mom where all the time yeah
it's [ __ ] crazy it's coming back now
don't throw your clothes away people
just give it like ten years it'll cycle
back and that people be like where you
get that [ __ ] it's like shit's [ __ ]
vintage honk it's all bridge and now
that's when a thrift shop started
getting really popular yeah election
when everybody was just only buying
thrift clothes you're like where'd you
get that [ __ ] I got at the thrift store
dude but the smell I can't deal with the
smell my still smells like somebody
else's [ __ ] yeah and I feel like it
it carries the soul of that [ __ ]
like I don't want that [ __ ] it's like
peeling a scab out of a human being and
putting that on your skin I don't want
to do that you know some people don't
want to buy stuff at garage sales if
they're old stuff because they feel like
the spirit of whatever that person who
used to own it is still in it
the energy transfer I have the energy
transfers of [ __ ] like that or or if
it's like from an estate estate sale
where somebody passed away and you don't
know how their spirit is still attached
to those things that's crazy I don't
want anything now oh yeah I don't want
you to even yeah I just want like maybe
I'll collect guns and watches that's it
but clothes everything I don't give a
[ __ ] man yeah I just want to eat food
and travel that's my [ __ ] I mean we all
got to that point to where we start to
realize where I think a lot of our
material stuff that that we thought we
really enjoyed I got it out of my system
oh for sure two up I mean I still like
clothes and stuff which I'm trying to
get to a comfortable weight because I
because I keep losing weight so I don't
want to go backwards and you know but I
got so like I think the one thing I will
buy his clothes and then probably like
furniture [ __ ] because I still have my
Honda Element
which I'm waiting for that [ __ ] to
explode first and then I'll buy a new
car I think I want to do clothes stuff
because I was like you know I was
thinking about it right I was like you
know right now I have an audience and
then I haven't really experimented with
style and I like it so I'm like I might
[ __ ] just do it just try it clothing
it's [ __ ] expensive man it is just
going to Nike and just getting my
workout clothes so that wore my workout
clothes to the max but you know how I
find hacks for everything
how so this thing came to mind right we
have a lot of fans yeah work at
different businesses yeah and we're
during the meet-and-greet in Boston
shoutouts to the homie he was like hey
use his coat I work at Reebok 50% off oh
[ __ ] I just [ __ ] bought a ton of [ __ ]
and I was like thanks dude
and then like other fans started
throwing me [ __ ] like hey I work at
so-and-so if you come into the store
I'll hook you up and then like so I
could build my whole arsenal of fashion
at a fraction of the price
hey I need my clothes so hit me up in my
Instagram DMS
that's what I'm saying all employees
please hit us up yeah man I need I need
a hookup yeah give me the employee codes
man please and then you know what if I'm
in your city we'll go have lunch I'll
[ __ ] hang out with you we'll talk
whatever yeah this podcast doesn't make
enough money for this show yet so so
dude even if I'm a billionaire
I love deals do you deal hunting yeah
[ __ ] good dude it's it's like a game
yep
you know like it's like I'm a deal hunt
all day I only like sharing the price of
stuff that I bought if I got a good deal
yeah like cuz like what's the point
right you're like you know how much I
got this watch for the same price you
could get it for you could just walk
into any Rolex store and get it for the
same price like so [ __ ] what dude I
like sharing [ __ ] like I forgot what did
I get recently that guy for [ __ ]
cheap man oh I signed up for this Bed
Bath & Beyond membership thing yeah and
it's like you get 20% off the store
site-wide and then there was something
on clearance it had the extra 20% off
and I got I got that [ __ ] for like it
was it was the coffee table the coffee
table originally was like 500 something
bucks and then I got it for like 280 and
I was high oh I like doing that too like
when there's a sale and then you can
knock off from a sale item you put a
coupon code and then you knock that off
and it's like 40% off oh this [ __ ]
Jackie said I got the setup banana and I
was looking at it in store and I was
like [ __ ] I like the way this [ __ ] looks
it's actually a long it's an olive long
coat long raincoat I was like yeah
that's just [ __ ] fly and I looked
back at it and it had like that it's
like a military print hoodie in the back
- looks [ __ ] dope I waited out it for
like two weeks
and then Christmas tale started coming
by this [ __ ] was 50% off and I got it
because I waited all so happy
damn so sometimes if I really like
something I can't wait
this is the most Asian conversation
we've ever had on the circuit hey I
don't give a [ __ ] dude I don't care how
much money I make I love a good deal the
heart of the deal is I do and so I I
still I still can't buy [ __ ] like back
in a day I will never buy [ __ ] yeah if I
really like it but if it's not on sale
or whatever I just wait like I have a
you know I bought like a $200
Harley jacket back in the day but I also
now since I have the money if I really
want it and I look at it and I'm like I
know when I walk out of the store I'm
gonna keep thinking about it yeah I will
get it but I'm kind of lucky because I
don't have those moments that much you
end that Michael Jackson [ __ ] bling
jacket hey that was a moment dawg I look
at the glove too man I will say this
though I think most people when they buy
that [ __ ] they buy it and they never
look at it this for war that [ __ ]
consistently for like three months I can
make use of it dude
yeah you're the only person that
adamantly [ __ ] defended Michael
Jackson when that documentary came out
and then everybody else started
defending him after yeah [ __ ] them I'm a
real homie you I've never seen somebody
defend somebody they've never met so
much in my life dude you're like [ __ ]
that [ __ ] that's just oh it was so shady
though a lot of the a lot of the facts
especially um after I mean I was getting
flack for this [ __ ] but that was one of
the funniest documentaries ever seen in
my life anybody it was you know anybody
who anybody that could go up I don't
give a [ __ ] if you say this is brave or
not if even if it is brave it's still
hard for me not to laugh at it this full
rate weight Robin Hobson said he had me
go into a corner spread my butt cheek so
he could look at my butthole Jack the
bow buddy he said that I was like I
don't believe you man I don't believe
you like you had me up into the point
you just said you to a Corey said spit
those butt cheeks baby look back at it
and I want you to look back into my like
I want to see that [ __ ] like I don't
know
that was a little skeptical I don't know
where Robinson I'm not victim-blaming or
anything man I'm just saying it's just
vision the visual is kind of funny and
for most people they don't get it
because they just don't have the same
yeah perspective you know like that's
the thing about comedy man it's like
it's not for everyone or that you know
everyone finds other things funny so you
know I don't know I don't know man IIIi
love it though I think it's [ __ ]
hilarious
Dawg I laughed at that and I was more -
was mortified and terrified but I also
laugh at the r.kelly document.all [ __ ]
just because you know why I laughed at
that documentary so hard it was because
number one they didn't have to extend it
to a thousand episodes yeah they could
have wrapped that [ __ ] up in about three
they milked it they milked the [ __ ] out
of it and then on top of that it was
just the stuff that our Kelly would do
it was so [ __ ] ridiculous it was like
a Chappelle sketch it was this full the
moment he got out of jail he went to go
check out a junior high yeah like come
on bro
like that's [ __ ] hilarious was
invincible thinks he's invincible yeah
he legit things he's invincible he ended
up [ __ ] like trapping a group he
during a trial on [ __ ] sexual
violence and [ __ ] like what the [ __ ]
he's [ __ ] crazy old yeah what that's
nuts
I'm voting for more i'll never defend
his as there's the truth there's so much
evidence there's a video of him pissing
on a girl dude I actually did my
research and I knew I followed the
Mikael case like prior to that
documentary a lot of people that came
out and they were pissed that Michael
all that they had no [ __ ] idea of the
prior allegations the prior trials all
that stuff they might have heard it or
whatever but a lot of people just didn't
[ __ ] know when that came out they
were very emotionally moved and in there
like well we have to give respect to the
victims and hear them out and I'm or
like I'm all for it man but you know
also like it's it's I think it's it's
okay to say that that's [ __ ] it's
okay like you're not saying like you
know like like all victims love or all
survivors of [ __ ] rape or molestation
you know our like cuz they'll be cuz
this is what I always get is like see
this is why people don't want to come
out is because like they don't people
don't believe them when they come out
and I'm all like no that's not the
reason it's because they actually
couldn't go through a criminal case
because the [ __ ] judge was like this
is ludicrous yeah like if this was legit
they would have gone through with the
criminal case
yeah they couldn't even get a [ __ ]
civil case like they look at that [ __ ]
in there like now this is [ __ ]
[ __ ] so then they had to come out
with a book and that flopped so then
they had to build this sensationalist
like documentary in order to drive some
type of awareness toward Michael or the
situation but like all right you know
our [ __ ] justice system even through
that [ __ ] out cuz they're like
there's no grounds for anything yeah
that's [ __ ] crazy there's absolutely
no grounds and no one knows that people
think that they just made a documentary
straight and I'm like damn dude you guys
don't even know [ __ ] yeah so there's
just a lot to it and the people that are
outraged I kind of feel for it because I
think you are coming from a good place
you know there's all there's also like
influencers and people that are
well-known that are speaking up against
it too but when you hear their arguments
and you hear where they're coming from
it all stems from one place which is I
saw the documentary I was very moved I
believe them and I think that Michael is
guilty that's all of their [ __ ]
none of them read the court cases none
of them went past and saw anything yeah
because their only thing because they're
only looking at that doc and saying
these are facts and but they haven't
done every documentary has a bias to it
yeah these are just facts I mean look at
look at for example what's they called
fast food that was a fast food nation on
Super Size Me super-sized Super Size Me
those numbers were all [ __ ] and so
when that when that doc came out
everybody was like oh my god I can't
believe and it was funny too there was
something very apparent in the
documentary so for example when he was
calculating all the numbers for the
calories for the caloric content for
everything on the menu he fudged all
those numbers but nobody it's it said on
that documentary and I remember him
saying it and he fudged all those
numbers and even me I just took those
numbers as fact and I didn't
double-check them and so I think
when we hear the word documentary we
automatically assume it's unbiased fact
yeah and so that's just what we're
basing things on and I'm not saying that
if you watch that that docu wouldn't
have been moved as [ __ ] but when you're
taking somebody's name and legacy and
you're damning them and you are openly
going out into a public forum and saying
and it's not jokes and you're like I
believe this this and that
when you've only seen one source of
information your your credibility kind
of gets a little shaky yeah and they
decided to take it off air because they
found a lot of inconsistencies so for
one the they basically they claimed that
he was being molested in the train train
station right but here's the issue is
that the train station was built when he
was already past seventeen years old
mmm that was a I think it was Jane with
his name safe Chuck hmm when he when he
claimed the medal of molestation
happened was like when he was like 10 or
11 or something yeah and to me that's a
hard stretch right like people were like
well he could forget and I'm like man a
lot of us know the difference between
junior high and high school okay what do
you mean he could forget night if you're
saying but the problem with that and the
fallacy in that statement is that
because there's the argument where
people have been putting on him it's
like well how do you remember all that
stuff as a kid cuz I can't remember that
stuff as a kid
yeah but all of a sudden when it comes
to that train fact you know they're like
oh he could he could know his memory
could be messed up it's a go which is it
like I can't what the [ __ ] you know so
there's a lot of inconsistencies like
that so they pulled the documentary off
they should have and it wasn't a
documentary it was just me it was a
sensational piece yeah they didn't even
research yeah so there's another
documentary that just came out called
square one mm-hmm and it's not a
rebuttal to that but it's based off of
the first case in 92 or something like
that yeah where Michael was first what
do you call it like accused right the
first one he was accused there's a whole
backstory about that and then the kid
that accused them
he's still living today but he doesn't
want to talk to the media but they've
interviewed all the people that he knew
and who he basically said yeah it was a
lie
and then there's just there's just a
whole lot of [ __ ] backstory about it
it's pretty dope
oh my god watch that [ __ ] square one
yeah I went to the screening it was
pretty cool
that year was it this year that those
Doc's came out the r.kelly [ __ ] it was
this year huh yeah this year was the
year of sensational documentary the fire
documentary the fire shout out to Andy
homie I was I was prepared to suck his
dick you know what the funny [ __ ] is
about that document at that moment I was
dying laughing because nobody asked the
guard if he wanted to get his dick
sucked they just were like you have to
suck his dick didn't even ask if he
wanted to get his dick sucked they just
assumed and this fool is gonna suck his
dick and he was like wait so I don't
just suck a dick he's like nah you're
not even my type dude I'm not gay bro
so this that's how stupid that [ __ ]
manager is he's like oh my god well
Andy's gay and he's gay you know what
you got a suck dick bro yeah it's gotta
[ __ ] do it
you'd even ask him like what the [ __ ]
how do you know how do you know it's
like it's like it's like straight dudes
who get freaked out by gay dudes and
they're like dude I want you to hit on
me it's like how do you how do you know
this yours type what the [ __ ] that's the
dumbest thing ever like what the [ __ ]
you don't know if he likes you or not my
god chill the [ __ ] out [ __ ] weirdos
well everybody that wraps up this
episode of the genius brain podcast oh
yeah yeah yeah yeah well it's quick it
was quick man that [ __ ] was like 50
minutes yeah well you guys already know
what to do man every Thursday's it's me
and Joe and we talk about [ __ ] we're
just here to accompany you on your
everyday lies and fill that empty quiet
void leave in the comments below if
you're watching this on the youtube
about [ __ ] that you want us to talk
about also to in the comments talk I
want you guys to talk and converse and
then leave comments and go back and
forth we probably say a lot of dumb [ __ ]
and if you misinterpret it that's all
good to man we just want you guys to
converse yeah we lurk in there and
sometimes we respond back too so go
ahead and have a whole last conversation
on just what you heard hell yeah because
we say a lot of dumb [ __ ] that
probably regret later so catch us on
Spotify catch us on iTunes stitcher or
whatever those audio platforms are you
will see this said if you see us on
iTunes give us that five star we [ __ ]
love you shout outs to you guys and
we'll see y'all next time
Party Time peace